[Music]
slow zoom into a waking cityscape the
streets are ready for action i've got a
good feeling this is going to be a
really awesome episode of law and order
was that a yawn usually i on after i see
someone else do it but this is a
half-assed attempt to make me feel the
weight of this man's work day maybe this
is foreshadowing how i may feel after
sinning this episode wearing sunglasses
at night while smoking a cigarette in a
tank top so you can so you can look like
even more of an [ __ ] from the 80s
neither one of these guys pulls the gun
up and out in any perceivable way so as
far as i can tell they've pulled the gun
sideways through the seam of their pants
i do not expect this trend to catch on
[Applause]
[Music]
consciously courteous concrete criminal
is a casual coffee cup conservationist
in a world of superpowered beings you
choose to observe the shadowy cafe
crusader instead of shooting him on site
before he goes rock hard for your base
he didn't even bring you a coffee after
stopping to get himself one that's
enough merit to blow away this discount
dwayne the rock johnson concreting your
head last instead of first this guy's
not killed instantly after being hit
with a forklift instead he and it's get
across the ground and are pinned up
against some racks that should have also
been killed in this event i'm guessing
the forklift was paying more attention
in its drama class than in physics
bringing in the big guns huh you sure
about that titan's been beating humans
with other humans and you think bringing
a bigger pew pew will do the job size in
this case doesn't matter titan's lack of
resourcefulness is playing a big part in
time spent dealing with these goons he's
been disarming these guys for what seems
like 15 minutes yet hasn't picked up a
gun to shoot back at them he could have
had enough time to enjoy a post beat
down vanilla bean latte before heading
home he wasn't taking his superpower for
granted thinking that screaming while
firing your weapon makes it more
effective
[Music]
good stab the rock band in the chest who
has been deflecting bullets during the
entire raid what's next eating soup with
a fork
why are these buttons on this phone
during playback since when do you need a
record button while you're watching your
footage and under what circumstances
would i need to select the front-facing
camera i'm just trying to watch my
latest tick-tock phone leave me alone
you went all the way across town to get
cheesecake yep to make up for being laid
because you went across town to get
cheesecake i was initially confused as
to why i didn't have two cheesecakes and
then i realized that amber and mark just
choose to communicate in the most
bizarre way possible however now i'm
just upset that i don't have two
cheesecakes so i'm gonna give them three
cents oh his pants aren't on fires
beyond me but since he always removes
his shirt i'm a little confused about
the blade and disregard for pants don't
tell me the rocks being shy about a
stalactite or possibly stalagmite
depending on the situation what did we
ever do to you kevin my man titan just
lit your entire apartment complex ablaze
as you watched i think the better
question is why you didn't immediately
call 9-1-1 when titans started to commit
arson after eating the cat villain i'm
guessing that invincible's more of a dog
person here i am throwing all my good
boots out trying to silence the
catcophony of alley cats next to my home
when i should be digging out my superman
halloween costume from 2012 and chucking
the cats through a wall this show has
made it clear i must dismantle the
invasion of the third meow led by the
fur
you've been late 12 times in the past
three months i'm sorry but i'm docking
your shifts does he mean talking his bay
because technically speaking it sounds
like mark is already docking his shifts
on his own racing
grayson getting batman in a non-dc
property
principal winslow taking family manners
name in vain without going full
crossover episode your lives worth
minimum wage or do you want to fire your
guns in the air say you tried your best
and we all walk away happy
and alive i can understand the confusion
this caused because even though they're
indoors air is still all around them but
it's still weird that the riders didn't
have at least one of these guards
consider the inevitable investigation
where they're gonna have to explain why
they all shot at the ceiling instead of
the perpetrator you're a walking pile of
rocks that's roxast i know where your
family lives and that means you work for
me until i say you're [ __ ] done this
excessive usage of auto-tune sure when
it's tastefully done it adds a
futuristic vibe that can supplement your
overall aesthetic but none of that even
rhymed t-pain is on the phone he wants
you off the tape bless now you got to
pay for the desk too this was imported
italian maple oh
nave if you had any inkling of exquisite
taste in the fine fashions of
woodworking chatels you'd be aware that
the african blackwood would complement
this office space better
invincible's ability to breathe the
varying altitudes remains frustratingly
confusing in episode four i had to
address the strangeness of him having
trouble breathing on mount everest when
in episode two he had no trouble holding
his breath for long periods in space and
now in episode 5 i have to address the
fact that he appears to be breathing at
all while hanging out somewhere near the
karman line when in episode 4 he was
having trouble breathing on mount
everest how's it feel to save the world
why not break the meteor into tiny
pieces with your super strength you said
a meteor hurling into deep space at such
a velocity that it would decimate any
planet in its trajectory for a date with
a girl that doesn't even like your
diversified cheesecakes i'm not sure
you're earning the hero part of
superhero
nobody awoke to their house being blown
apart my dog would have lost his hearing
invincible outside of his home never
mind getting a portion of your garage
blown away not to mention the lights are
on so people are awake did somebody ask
for butterscotch ripple the show's
already spent a considerable amount of
time showing us that titan isn't all
that bad so much so that the suggestion
of him about to attack a child feels so
out of character that this ice cream
turn isn't the least bit surprising also
pretending that butterscotch is a
child's favorite ice cream flavor
forcing elephants back into captivity he
calls himself
i'll admit this title card's funny every
time but at 15 minutes in it'd be
funnier if you just continued on with
this momentum that the stories created
and by funnier i just mean better
facebook also artists thought that just
because dark blood was a demon he'd be
committed to the whole evil notebook of
the dead aesthetic when he was clearly
throwing a more hip moleskin vibe what
was the name of that place in bordeaux
the one with the chocolate pastry
thingies show dangles this delicious
sounding pastry thread in front of us
but doesn't follow it a single bit
further leaving notes without context so
when you go back to do further research
you cannot for the life of you remember
why you wrote down cubits a moose bouche
and donnie benay all guys make mistakes
using your man card to justify the
betrayal of trust i tried using that
statement once when i super glued my
finger and my belly button the outcome
was the same you just look like an idiot
you're an 18 year old girl
you can't do this hero [ __ ] on your
own
parents rearrange atoms on a molecular
level like it's easy wait i thought all
she could do was weird pink energy
things i had no idea she put doors in
weird places where was that during the
interdimensional alien invasion also
conjuring a door mid-wall and without
consent you know i'm more like a big
picture superhero pretending that you're
as important and relevant as a marvel or
dc hero you do know you're on amazon
right
letting your pride get in the way of
experiencing flight may be [ __ ] to
you titan but somewhere out there as a
kid dreaming of being ferried to the bad
places of the city by their favorite
superhero machine head owns the trash
company
uses it to ferry drugs to stash houses
all over the city using the trash bins
is clever but garbage trucks have to be
the most impractical truck for this job
for one you don't put trash cans inside
them because there's all that compactor
tech in there and two even if you did
manage to cram one or two trash cans in
there good luck getting them out without
attracting attention to what should be a
covert operation just saying machine
head seems like you'd be smarter than
this even though people use it
generically popsicle's a trademark name
you wouldn't see a kleenex palace would
you although really might be handy to
have one next to the popsicle palace now
that i think about it i know i can take
machine head he's just a criminal with a
special head having a special head is
often a sign of huge problems for a
superhero modoc brainiac juggernaut
doesn't he read comic books putting
mashed potatoes right on top of your
already separated food you fought off an
alien invasion save the country from an
asteroid this is beneath you filter my
classism that's the last time the lizard
league turns people into snakes in my
town the lizard league missed
opportunity for the name snake society
or serpent squad why did the lizard
league choose to turn people into snakes
instead of lizards sure they're both
reptiles but everyone knows that lizard
people are far superior to snake people
it's like filter my classes in 101. but
so caught up in your own little prize
fights that you let this entire bus of
civilians crash liar monster girl's
fighting but rex looks like he's taking
a long happy second to observe the menu
of a burger mart down the road or that
he just enjoys hearing the sound of
screeching tires and children on fire as
usual i'll be the only person who
actually sacrificed something since i'm
now a week younger than i was yesterday
kids he's only been a hero for a few
months he thinks he knows everything i
just don't want him to make a choice
he'll regret like sloppy slaughtering an
entire superhero team without doing much
to cover your painful barefoot lego
trail of evidence like that regret you
want to come tonight we could use the
help
i wish i could but too busy saving the
world well done amber you've
accidentally put two and two together
about eve's superhero career but how are
you still oblivious to marx he's been
coming more in and out of your life than
my dad has in mind just don't let mark
go get milk
hi i'd like to schedule a therapy
appointment i almost forgot how good i
look button press buff blue man reveal
technology electricity excitement
three-point landing cliche debbie's
calculations show 12th minute of travel
time while she sets a timer for 20
minutes i can look past this discrepancy
as a possible estimate to account for
wait times at each stop but there are so
many unknown variables here such as
nolan's flight speeds and just how long
is he willing to wait at these shops he
doesn't seem to be a very patient man so
the fact that the timer goes off exactly
when he gets back makes this whole scene
a conveniently contrived pile of this
works nolan put his murder suit on this
weird shelf above the window instead of
sinking into the bottom of the ocean
tossing into an active volcano or just
throwing it straight into the sun now
even on the off chance he planted it
here on purpose i'm still giving this a
sin because throwing it into the sun
wasn't plan a oh yeah these guys know
what's up it doesn't matter how good you
are at security as much as how cool you
look doing it no way you saw this come
on i mean i did not because i'm watching
you do it now titan but because this
building was foreshadowed four times in
the industry we call this foreshadowing
it's not quite as wasteful as doing four
score shadowing but still a bit much
which is how i know it's not worth
explaining to you two morons what
quantum probabilities are well machine
head is right simply because that would
take a lot of time and it's not like
they're paying him for this lecture so
he'd only have an incentive to do this
if he was the type of person that
derived value from sharing his wisdom
with others clearly he is not that being
said his statement about probability
evokes an alarming amount of certainty
so much so that i'm wondering if someone
needs to explain to him what quantum
probabilities are mixing food with one
hand you look like you're good at
chopping things
how'd you know cause she's a super never
mind wait invisible is bloodied when did
that happen he gets covered in lava and
electricity and smashed into a wall and
a floor then uppercut by big the cat
with a mace and then this
is where you want to show damage on him
it's almost like you want him to be
impervious until the plot needs him to
bleed whatever the case the show's name
from this point should now be
occasionally vincible
who's next not reading the room
not reading your texts wait wait i'm
getting something here what
not using the already blown out door for
maximum property damage cecil got an
anonymous call samson feels the need to
deliver this information which is pretty
much like the paramedic showing up to
your car crash finding you bleeding out
and pausing to explain that someone
called them and that not happened they
wouldn't be there
these [ __ ] taco bell's new slogan
somehow makes it into the episode not to
tell machine head how to spend his own
money but he could have just had isotope
teleport battle beast here instead of
wasting his money on the rest of these
goons take it from confucius machine
head he who will not economize will have
to agonize
this fight was so good i'm not even
going to call it a discount thanos
versus hulk in fact this fight is so
good marvel should take notes this fight
is so good i'm taking a sin away and
attitude to the next marvel show in
spite i'm gonna make this city better
for a lot of people
some people come first
inviting your family to a bloodied
battle-ridden office doesn't seem like
the best parental choice to preserve
child innocence just look up honey just
look up having the secret lab be
accessible from the main elevator not
only creates opportunities for these
awkward interactions it also increases
the likelihood that an individual like
myself could hack their way into the lab
not with skill but with immature button
mashing i'm like an expert button masher
watch
uh
oh
oh um
cindy
can you fix that
[Music]
thanks
you've dropped your rock
hansel
so hot right now
surprise [ __ ]
is he a good guy
you can't handle the truth what was the
name of that place in bordeaux the one
with the chocolate pastry thingies how
can you think of food at a time like
this who's your boss
[Music]
machine head owns the trash company
uses it to ferry drugs to stash houses
all over the city beautiful super
awesome sexy stash house the only place
we're guaranteed to find machine head is
60 stories up inside this building there
is a level where no elevator can go
and no stare can reach and i need all of
you to stop what you're doing and listen
cannonball
[Applause]
this battle is beneath me
not quite my tempo yeah i mean it sounds
about like bunk that's about it right
there's not much more to it in it i'll
fix you we have the technology